well just wait a moment as people are joining I do apologize for tonight's delay we
just completed the Shema and readings with the celebrate mercy audience and we just had to
extend it a little bit longer but inshallah this is the beginning of our nightly gatherings
in Ramadan and the idea of this gathering is is that it's a very brief reminder
insha'Allah so we're not going to be together for too long because the intention is that
we spend a lot more time in personal worship in any battle with Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala but the idea is is to really reflect on one of the prophetic dot that
is is taught to us by the prophet mohammed salah salem whether he's taken from the
Quran or the prophesy sedums life or inspired by the prophet mohammed salah salem but to
live in these under and to have something with us as we are making our do
as we're spending time in the night with Allah subhana WA Ta'ala were calling upon Allah
were you know pleading with Allah subhana WA Ta'ala and as we've been talking about the
doha is is such an essential and critical component of our relationship with allah subhanaw taala
in the space of worship well a bad you know supplicating is worship and so we
want to make sure that this Ramadan we have a very healthy conversational relationship with Allah
we spend as much time talking to Allah and I would recommend that we are making
dua before method as you know those last moments before the other I know none of
it whether it's you know 15 minutes or 30 minutes before or 10 minutes before even
5 minutes depending on your schedule take time to really carve out to call upon allah
subhanaw taala anytime between a van and hama you know and we have massaged it in
our home now so insha'Allah every time that we have a moment of event in a
moment of calm over sitting down that is a time before du-ha the latter part of
the night is from the most sacred times of dua and stuff it in I've been
as hard those who are seeking forgiveness in the moments of in those early morning hours
and so all of these are precious times where we can make dua in the times
of Bella in the times of hardship it is you know a time of doing in
the time of rain it is a time of dua and etc and certainly Ramadan is
a month of
da-da-da-da-da and if any hurry ug booed our today either done if my caught my servants
call then ask about me then let them know that I'm closer I'm there I am
close and I respond to the call of the caller of he or she calls and
so we have to come to Allah subhana WA Ta'ala in a state in us in
a disposition of humility in a disposition of mascara that we are in need of him
and at this position of imploring allah subhanaw taala and begging allah and you know and
and really you know al l ha where we ask allah in in a form that
is that is incessant in nature that i asked a lot i ask allah i ask
allah bring your worries bring your concerns bring your fears bring your pains bring your stress
bring your aspirations bring it all to Allah subhana WA Ta'ala and spend that quality time
in sha allah who tada I wanted to begin this
sessions with this dua this will be the first day that we cover in this 30
day series in these 30 sessions and that is the dua of of worry and anxiety
and fear and stress being lifted and I you know how I felt that this had
this dua is so relevant to our particular states right now in the circumstances that we're
going through you can find this door I think I posted it in the above the
video so you can read the Arabic and the English the translation as well as the
transliteration so I'll read it in Arabic and you can follow along and you know prepare
your heart and then I'll explain it briefly insha allah la ilaha illa allah Duke even
though our Vedic even automatic now so a TV addict Marvin fee Rahman Adlon fear about
as a localized mean who alec sometta be enough suck and Zelda who Viki Tabak our
lambda ho I had a mean hullick I was thought to be here l meanwhile in
the entire Quran and Alina Robby aqua Lumina or a miracle be onerous Adri well Jenna
whose knee was a heavy hand me this is a beautiful dua of the prophet muhammad
sallallaahu said no more he says o Allah I am your servant and I am the
son of your servant the son of your maidservant my forelock is in your hand ie
you have total mastery over me you know this is this is the most beautiful expression
of surrender I am your servant the son of your male servant the from some of
your female servant I am your servant now see a TB addict you know my entire
forelock my entire neck is in your hand meaning you have categorical in complete control over
me and that is from the ED above dua is the praise of allah and to
illustrate humility in in the Magnificent court of allah subhana WA Ta'ala and this is a
beautiful way to express that your command over me is forever executed and your decree over
me is just meaning that whatever you want allah subhanaw taala will certainly be will certainly
be and i know that i can never exist outside of your decree and none of
us for that matter can have any choices outside of the decree of allah subhanaw taala
and what you decree for me Allah is the best it is what is most fair
because this is from Allah and this is the disposition of the humble servant that I
have I acknowledge your decree I acknowledge that your decree is upon me all the time
and that you decree only the best of things for me and then the prophet sallallaahu
Selim says I ask you by every name belonging to you which you named yourself with
or revealed in your book or you talked to any of your creation or you have
preserved in the knowledge of the unseen with you so this is the expression of the
prophesy send them to illustrate that Ya Allah I know that you have inglis names endless
descriptives and so he's asking with every possible Avenue of potentially where names making four come
from whether they are names that he has named himself that he sent to us in
Revelation that he's talked to some of his creation that he has kept for him in
the unseen realm and all of this build up is to ask for what I asked
you a lot that you make the Quran the life of my heart and the light
of my breasts the light of my chest that's what the process LM is seeking as
he experienced divine revelation in that first moment the words of allah subhanaw taala the revealed
text the holy scripture the book of healing and clarity and increase in illumination
Allah I ask you to make the Quran the life of my heart and the light
of my chest and is this not the most appropriate way for us to begin the
month of Ramadhan that we ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala in his magnificent in endless names
that he makes the Quran the life of our of our hearts and that he illuminates
our chests because we're bringing and this is a dua that is specifically utilized for what
for the removal of worry and angst and concern and fear and hardship because when the
ad is embedded in me and the Quran is embedded in you then all of those
other negative realities they simply become overshadowed and they they are they are brought light is
brought into the being by the Quran and
everything else is expelled and so we want Allah and we go to Allah with humility
because Allah he gives the the sacred keys of the Quran and this light he gives
it to those who deserve it and those who seek it and and to deserve it
I have to seek it sincerely and I have to want it and I have to
believe in the power of the Quran but you make the Quran the life of my
heart and the light of my chest and a departure from my sorrow and a release
for my anxiety we ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to make this dua a reality in
our nights of Ramadan
so let us repeat this dua together after understanding it after internalizing it's Mirani after falling
in a state of humility at the doorstep of the majestic we come to Allah in
the state of masks Anna a state of of impoverishment the state of need knowing that
our realities are fully and completely and utterly in the hands of Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
and that we are categorically reliant upon him we say a la una in me and
repeat with me in sha allah allahumma
inni and if you need to you can read the transliteration allahumma inni a baduk he
knew a Vedic every new emit emetic now see a TV addict Marvin fee hawk MOOC
admin fee kabak as a Luka beacon this man who anak cimetidine of sack o and
delta who Fickett arabic Alentejo adam in holic i was taught to behave here L mean
ye beer in Dec entity Allah Ya Allah and tell Adam karana Ravi Akali be well
Newroz Audrey was Jenna whose knee whether had her me alone a menial banana mean we
ask allah subhanaw taala to beautify us with the dua of the prophet muhammad salallahu alayhi
wasalam may you use this do I mean we all use this dua as we turn
to Allah and we talk to Allah and we supplicate to Allah may Allah make us
of those who always call upon him and never disconnect ourselves from him and are always
in conversation with him may these nights be alive in the vicar and the remembrance of
Allah in sauna into a in Vick in km
ensued in the war may Allah bring life to our nights with the Quran may the
Quran be present with us accompanying us throughout our nights and throughout our days may we
never be disconnected from the Quran maybe not be amongst those who the prophet salallahu alaihe
salam lamented to allah in nepal me tejada hoddan for an Amur Allah my people they
neglected the Quran Ya Allah make us of those who are always of the Quran make
us an and never allow us to be amongst those who left the Quran Allah bring
life to us through the Quran bring life to a through Salah and through the allahumma
Ameen barakallahu li walakum Ramadan Kareem Ramadan Mubarak may lost Rantala help us to have p.m.
lane every single night in these blessed days and may Allah grant us salvation in these
nights may he grant us and it may he grant us that we are saved in
these nights and that we are written amongst the people of Jannah and that we exit
this month with clean slates as our mother's bird us and that we exit this month
in this month in the best of States better than what we entered into this month
with categorically and may we find our burdens lifted and our worries removed in our fears
eliminated and may we be together with our loved ones in this life and be evening-night
Allah in the company of an Habib al mustafa sallallahu alayhi wasallam in the afterlife allahu
Medina Sidonia Hassan our fill IATI Hassan of Akina a turban our table moti Toba rind
and moti Shahada other than note e Jonathan una rima or Solander whom allah sayidina muhammad
wa our hero DeWanna and l-hamdu lillahi rabbil aalameen assalamualaikum warahmatullah